you said that there are very few perfect  movies and one of them is Texas Chainsaw  Massacre yes  what are the other perfect movies well  there's not many of them that just  bemoans that the fact that like you know  the film art form is hard and look when  you say perfect movies you're talking  about you know any individual person's  aesthetic but even trying to account for  all Aesthetics even but the perfect  movie kind of crosses all Aesthetics to  one degree or another might not be your  cup of tea but there's nothing you can  say to bring it down I think Jaws fits  into that  I thank the exorcists  I think Annie Hall fits into that oh God  Annie well  oh well some people could say uh Young  Frankenstein that's Frankenstein Back to  the Future  [Music]  is a perfect Perfect movie yeah perfect  movie yeah